as I've asked the candidates to join me
here on the stage and what I've eclair
the result each of them will be invited
to say a few words if they wish starting
with a successfully elected individual
and so to the formal announcement of the
results for the election of a member of
parliament of the ASB constituency held
on the center may 2015 I angiograms
being the acting returning officer at
the aforementioned direction do hereby
give notice that the number of votes
recorded for each candidate is as
follows Adams Christopher mark you Kip
scrap hs2 ten thousand nine hundred and
twenty five Kass William Alexandra
Labour Party 8390 one
Steven Michael Liberal Democrat 5885
little David Roy the Conservative Party
candidate 28,000
say Richard
green party candidate 2135 and i hereby
declare that David Roy Liddington is
duly elected to serve as Member of
Parliament for the aylesbury
constituency the number of other papers
rejected was as follows want of an
official mark Neil voting form all
candidates and voters in title 278
writing or mark I which motive could be
identified five being unlocked or wholly
void for uncertainty 152 totaling 235
and the turnout was 68 point zero six
percent thanking all right now like to
ask David Lidington to say a few words
is my first and very pleasant duty to
thank you and all your staff both who've
been on counting duty here this evening
and all those stars who've been working
at the polling stations throughout the
constituency during today from very
early hours to ensure that this election
proceeded smoothly second I want to say
a big thank you to my agent Sarah sprout
and to the volunteers from the aylesbury
constituency Conservative Association
who have worked so hard to make this
evening victory possible it is a
privilege and honor to have been
reelected to serve a sixth term as
Member of Parliament for this
constituency and I again commit myself
to working on behalf of every
constituent no matter how he or she may
have voted and no matter what views he
or she may hold it is too early to be
clear about the outcome nationally but
it looks as if it has been a good
evening for the Conservative Party in
this country but I think it is important
to that our party recognizes that we
have tonight being entrusted with many
votes from people who are willing to
give us a further chance but who want to
see us pursue objectives that very clear
are serving the common
good of people from all parts of our
country and all hearts of society early
on the committee to doing whatever I can
to help ensure that a successful economy
bears fruit to benefit everyone in this
country and to seek to bring about
reconciliation respect and unity amongst
the diverse range of people who live in
aylesbury and in the United Kingdom
thank you very much